votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
tu as un mec oui comme ils s'appellent
phone
je ne sens donné s'appelle comment ce
genre rené jean rené
[Applaudissements]
on embrasse son run et qui doit être
actuellement dans le public des chiffres
et des lettres tapées jean-rené si tu
dors pas encore écouté va entamer ces
jeux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
salut je reconnais ça commençait à mon
chéri ça bien trouver quoi dans la vie
je suis agent immobilier avec un prénom
comme ça tu pourrais travailler en
maison de retraite
on peut l'appeler jsc quoi oui oui merci
r oui mais vous voulez pas vous
applaudir une menorah malagache à moi
c'est pas vraiment une anecdote je vais
je vais révéler quelque chose - comme
valérie jeu pas beaucoup partis au ski
donc la vraie seule fois c'était avec
vous l'amour genève on va révéler
quelque chose
le bâton était plus grand qu'elle c'est
clair non on passait des journées un peu
chargées
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui ça c'est une vérité non ce qui s'est
passé là au ski qu'on ne verra pas
évidemment ce soir c'est qu'on on
passait des journées voilà assez
harassante tous ensemble c'est très très
bien entendu et je suis désolé de
révéler sa mémoire
après une longue journée de ski pendant
que tous les soirs on avait pour 1,8 id
elle va désolé massart jaune et on était
en avait pour habitude d'aller boire un
dernier verre dans un championnat si on
fait un gros match aurait alors la dose
parce que des fois et nous on n'est pas
du tout au courant
allez matthieu delormeau à l'or
jean-robert papa rené rey
[Applaudissements]
là c'est énorme et doha les i après une
soirée qu'on avait tous terminés tous
ensemble dans votre chance d'avoir des
petits coussins pas moi je vois pas non
mais des petits coups de coca fin de
soda et donc dans sa chambre doucement
quoi et avec ben ali c'est l'acteur ian
a vécu je vous jure qu'elle avait une
qui venait dans ma chambre tous les
soirs c'est noté alors toi qui venait
dans la mienne
et d'ailleurs nous révélons pas tout
suivez là il va alors justement en
parlant de chambre oui chacun est rentré
dans ses pénates
ouais et au bout d'un moment j'entends
un petit grattements à la porte je me
dis mais qui vient m'embêter à 1h du mat
et c'était la capsule et à capuche elle
aurait bien aimé avoir l'air un petit
bisou magog et nos papilles est venu
mais c'est énorme en me disant hainaut
c'est en victoire après je sentais sont
si vous cherchez quelque chose dans
l'immobilier tu me demandais à quoi l'on
stocke la peau de lanvaux parce que
j'aimerais là c'est quoi ton budget
abbas ont bon dos leurs mots c'est
budget limité
non je crois à des prêts faits avec le
contrat qui va signer sur nt1 bunker atp
mp moi bretzel particulier si nous feras
tu sais quoi
mais lui un [ __ ] de cabanes
particulière jésus comme chez vous quoi
jamais dû comme chez vous comme suis
venu une fois allait bien mais
malheureusement c'est déjà pris chacun
va se coucher et puis bonne quarantaine
de minutes après je suis en pyjama et
tout je suis sous la couette et
j'entends même pas quelqu'un toqués
j'entends quelqu'un gratter vraiment
gras t elle alors c'était parce que
gratter ça peut être juste avec son nez
alors j'ai tout de suite pensé agissant
main armée et j'ai ouvert la porte et
j'ai vu notre notre cas pas pu lui qui
m'a dit voilà
qu inattendue une proposition est alors
de câlins alors alors j'ai refusé mais
c'est pas bluff non flex ligue 1 ou par
non alors non non pourtant nul ne peut
nier qu'il ya eu décès pour les bleus
ouais ouais mais n'a jamais juste un
vide est donc d'essayer d'embrasser une
fille non bah oui il m'a parlé de plus
mais j'aimerais la plus belle vous
auriez des bahamas une perruque
valérie c'est génial d'embrasser une
fille et un garçon en même temps
c'était tout le temps dans sa chambre au
comice travers vous avez faire une noce
bah oui oui je voulais qu'on fasse de
nous étions dans quel hôtel levens lui
faire changer touax alors écoutez sa
recette mais il a raison annecy bah je
vais parler j'aime autant vous dire
qu'il est agréable a réservé ses
intérêts quoi vous étiez à l'arrivée le
restaurant a ajouté que ça qui les a
mariés vous le peuple pape pie xii
c'est le cardinal de richelieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]